[S01] 2021 年的某一天
[S01] 半个互联网呃突然之间就陷入了瘫痪
[S02] 没错，是大面积的
[S01] 对，Reddit 宕机了，Mozilla 的服务断了，连那个领英也瘫了，你猜是因为什么超级黑客的攻击吗？其实根本不是
[S02] 原因其实非常扯
[S01] 对吧？仅仅是因为全球时钟为了修正地球自转的误差，硬生生地增加了一个闰秒，就是说时间在系统的世界里倒流了一秒，或者说那一分钟变成了61 秒，结果
[S02] 结果就是成千上万的服务器集体陷入了恐慌，直接罢工了
[S01] 欢迎来到今天的深度解析。你每天都在手机上刷着各种极其流畅的APP，点击刷新，一切都显得那么自然，但你可能从来没意识到，在这份丝滑体验的背后，究竟隐藏着怎样一个由硬件故障、网络延迟，还有时间错乱构成的，怎么说呢？极其混乱的物理世界
[S02] 确实是个混乱的世界。我们作为用户啊，早就习惯了那种被人精心包装过的错觉。你点个按钮，页面瞬间刷新，干净利落，感觉就像是一台完美的数字机器在运转。但这恰恰是因为底层有无数的工程师在帮你疯狂掩盖现实的残酷
[S01] 而这正是我们今天要带你潜入的深海。我们今天手头有一份非常硬核的资料，被无数程序员奉为圭臬的经典著作，《设计数据密集型应用》
[S02] 也就是大家常说的 DDIA
[S01] 对，DDIA。今天我们要重点死磕它的第三章和第九章。我们的任务其实很简单，就是为你拨开现代软件架构的这些迷雾，去看看数据到底是怎么被巧妙组织的，以及那些大厂的系统到底是怎么在随时可能崩溃的现实世界里坚强存活下来的。
[S02] 这绝对是一趟充满顿悟时刻的探索之旅。
[S01] 没错，今天没有那些晦涩的术语朗读，我们只讲那些让工程师们经常抓狂的硬核事实。好，我们来拆解一下，在面对物理世界的混乱之前，我们得先知道应用程序在逻辑上到底是怎么思考和存储数据的。
[S02] 嗯，这就不得不提数据模型了，这是所有系统的地基。
[S01] 对于非开发者来说，数据模型听起来呃挺抽象的。我看到资料里花了很多篇幅去对比什么关系模型和文档模型，这两个东西到底有什么根本区别？
[S02] 呃，我们可以用一个你很熟悉的场景来打个比方。假设哈你要在数据库里存一个人的领英简历，如果你用传统的关系型数据库来存，这个过程其实是非常暴力的。
[S01] 暴力？怎么个暴力法？
[S02] 就是你得把这个人的生活硬生生地拆散，你不能直接存一份完整的简历。
[S01] 哦，那要怎么存？
[S02] 你得把他的基本信息，比如名字、年龄，塞进一个叫用户表的地方，然后把他的前三份工作经历拆出来，塞进工作经验表，最后再把他的大学文凭塞进教育背景表。
[S01] 这听起来就像是把一个人的档案大卸八块。
[S02] 对，就是大卸八块。然后每次你要在网页上展示这个人的完整主页时，数据库就得去这三个不同的表里到处翻找，最后再用复杂的代码把它们重新缝合起来。这里真正迷人的地方在于，在工程学上，这种别扭的翻译过程被称为对象关系不匹配。
[S01] 也就是传说中的阻抗不匹配，对吧？
[S02] 没错。
[S01] 听起来确实很笨重，就像是我为了给你看一份文件，非得把你拉到三个不同的档案柜前面，一个一个找资料。那文档模型呢，比如现在大家都在用的那个杰森格式，
[S02] 文档模型就直观太多了。它就像是你直接拿了一个文件夹，把这个人所有的经历、学历、联系方式原封不动的打包成一个完整的杰森文档，直接塞进去。
[S01] 一锅端了。
[S02] 对，当需要加载主页的时候，一次读取所有信息全出来了，这就叫极佳的数据局部性。而且它还有一种所谓的读时模式的灵活性。
[S01] 等等，读时模式，这又是个什么概念？
[S02] 呃，就是说你不需要提前去定义死板的表结构，就像编程语言里的动态类型一样，数据先存进去，等读出来的时候，代码自己去解释它是什么。而在关系模型里，你必须提前建好每一根柱子，这叫写时模式。
[S01] 我有个问题啊，既然这个杰森文档这么灵活，读取又这么快，那为什么我们不干脆就是把所有的东西都塞进一个超级大的文档里呢？
[S02] 哈哈，这就问到点子上了。
[S01] 是吧？比如说把一个拥有上亿粉丝的大V,他所有的粉丝列表，每一条点赞甚至评论全写进他的这一个个人资料文档里，这不是一劳永逸吗？
[S02] 这就是很多初学者呃经常踩的一个巨大的坑。
[S01] 真的有人这么干？
[S02] 绝对有。但资料里用X,也就是以前的推特，它的主页时间线举了个非常棒的反例。你想啊，如果你把成千上万的点赞和评论全都塞进同一个文档里，那个文档会变得极其庞大。最致命的是写操作。
[S01] 写操作，就是别人去点赞的时候。
[S02] 对，每次只要有任何一个人点了个赞，整个系统就必须得去打开这个巨大的文档，修改那一小小的数字，然后再把这个庞然大物重新保存一遍。这在极高规模的并发下，性能开销是极其昂贵的，系统绝对会崩溃。
[S01] 哇，所以根本就没有什么万能药。文档虽然灵活，但太大也会成为负担。那为了性能，系统实际上是怎么做的？
[S02] X在实际的时间线缓冲中采取了一种极其巧妙的反规范化策略。为了快，他们的缓冲里根本就不存帖子的完整内容。
[S01] 那存什么？
[S02] 仅仅只存帖子ID和发帖人用户ID就两串数字。
[S01] 就存两个ID.那我们平时在屏幕上看到的那些头像文字到底是怎么瞬间显示出来的？
[S02] 这就全靠应用程序在最后一刻去发力了。当你刷新时间线的时候，代码会拿着这些ID瞬间并发去执行一些极快的查询，把发帖人的头像帖子的具体文本给补全。英文里管这个叫hydrating,就像给脱水蔬菜注水一样。
[S01] 这个注水的比喻很形象。也就是说，在那种极其恐怖的流量规模下，规范化还是反规范化，根本没有绝对的对错。
[S02] 对，全都是读写成本之间的权衡。
[S01] 好，接下来才是真正有趣的地方。就算我们在逻辑侧面把这些ID和文档组织的再完美，数据终究是要离开内存的，它得顺着网线一头扎进我们刚才说的那个残酷的物理世界里。
[S02] 是的，真正的挑战才刚刚开始。
[S01] 我必须得说，看完资料里的现实案例，我大受震撼。我一直以为网络中断呃，都是因为什么高科技的软件故障，结果资料上说海底光缆是会被鲨鱼咬断的。
[S02] 哈，鲨鱼确实对海底光缆情有独钟。
[S01] 还有陆地上的光纤居然会被吃草的牛给踩断，甚至还有海狸去啃电缆。
[S02] 对，加拿大的海狸可是断网界的主力军。如果我们把这和更大的图景联系起来看，你就会发现物理层的现实有多荒诞。在分布式系统里，SERVER之间唯一的沟通桥梁就是网络，而这种网络叫异步分布网络。
[S01] 异步分组网络这个词听起来挺吓人的，它到底是个什么意思？
[S02] 简单来说，它不仅随时可能因为各种奇葩原因断开，更让人绝望的是它有一种特性叫无界延迟。
[S01] 无界延迟。如果用交通来打个比方，现在的互联网数据传输是不是就像是一条永远在动态拥堵的高速公路，所有的车也就是数据包都在里面疯狂抢道。
[S02] 没错。
[S01] 所以你根本不知道你的那辆车到底会在路上被堵多久，可能一毫秒，也可能是一分钟。
[S02] 完全不知道，这就叫数据包交换。
[S01] 但我有个疑问啊，在老式的电话网络时代，那种叫电路交换的技术，不就像是为你专门预留了一条VIP车道吗？
[S02] 对，打电话的时候确实是这样。
[S01] 只要电话一接通，这条线就只属于你俩，没别人抢到，延时是绝对固定的。那现在拥有几万台服务器的大型数据中心，为什么不干脆采用那种绝对可靠的VIP车道技术呢？大家都省心啊。
[S02] 这其实是一个非常残酷的商业妥协。你想想，如果你为每个网络连接都预留一条数数的VIP车道，这就意味着当你在这条车道上，哪怕有一秒钟没发数据，整个带宽就被白白浪费掉了。
[S01] 哦，沾着茅坑不拉屎。
[S02] 花草里不唱，动态的高速公路虽然会带来排队拥堵，甚至造成你刚才说的无界延迟，但它最大化了整个物理硬件的利用率，把成本降到了最低。
[S01] 所以说便宜但不可靠的网络，是我们为了享受今天这种廉价的全球化互联网必须付出的代价。
[S02] 完全正确。
[S01] 如果你是一个正在听节目的开发者，你现在可能已经在心里嘀咕了。不对啊，我们底层不是有TCP协议吗？教科书上不都是TCP是可靠的吗？丢了包会自动重传啊。
[S02] TCP确实会在底层帮你重传，但它掩盖不了一个非常致命的盲区。
[S01] 什么盲区？
[S02] 我们拆解一下TCP的原理，你发一个请求过去，对方处理完回你一个确认叫ACK.但如果网络突然极度拥堵呢？
[S01] 对啊，拥堵了会发生什么？
[S02] 回到你那个高速公路的比喻，网络交换机就像是高速公路上的收费站，它自带一个用来排队的缓冲器。当车太多，收费站彻底排满了时候，你猜交换机会怎么做？
[S01] 怎么做？让后面的车排队等着。
[S02] 不，它没有那么优雅，它会直接把多出来的车推下悬崖。
[S01] 推下悬崖，这太暴力了吧。
[S02] 这就是网络世界里的丢包。而且最可怕的是，当你的服务器发了个请求出去，等了半天却没收到回应时，TCP根本无法分辨到底发生了什么。
[S01] 等等，也就是说我不知道是我的请求在半路上被推下悬崖了。
[S02] 对。
[S01] 还是说对方接收端的服务器突然断电宕机了？
[S02] 也有可能。
[S01] 或者最糟糕的，对方其实已经成功处理了我的请求，甚至已经把钱从我的账户里扣掉了。但是那个返回来的处理成功的确认包，在回来的路上被推下悬崖了。
[S02] 没错，面对这种绝对的不可置信，系统唯一能做的就是无奈的设一个超时。
[S01] Timeout
[S02] 对，比如设定个三十秒，三十秒没收到确认，我就单方面宣布你死了。
[S01] 这太冤了吧，那台服务器可能根本就没死，它只是被网络卡住了。既然网络这么不靠谱，消息可能被任意延迟，那系统到底依靠什么来确定事情发生的先后顺序呢？比如大家同时去抢同一张周杰伦的演唱会门票，总得有个先来后到吧，我们总该能相信服务器上的时钟吧。
[S02] 这就引出了一个极其重要的问题，也是分布式系统里最大的谎言，对时间的信任。
[S01] 时间也会撒谎，现在不是都是用原子钟或者NTP时间同步服务器了吗？
[S02] 事实上，服务器主板上的石英钟会随着机房的温度变化发生漂移。
[S01] 温度变化都能影响时间。
[S02] 对啊，而且你说的NTP同步服务，它本身不也得依赖我们刚才说的那种不可靠的网络吗？所以同步本身就会产生巨大的误差，更别提你开头提到的闰秒事件了，让整个互联网崩溃，就因为系统完全没想到时间还能往回走走。
[S01] 也就是说，绝对精准的时间在系统里是不存在的。这让我想到很多开发者在处理数据冲突的时候，特别喜欢用一种叫最后写入生理的策略，也就是LW.简单说就是看谁的时间戳更新，谁就覆盖旧的数据。听你这么说，这岂不是个定时炸弹？
[S02] 绝对的定时炸弹。比较两个不同节点的本地时钟是极其危险的。假设啊节点A的时钟因为误差比节点B慢了整整一分钟。
[S01] 好，AB慢一分钟。
[S02] 这是节点B先写了一条数据，时间戳是十点零一分。过了一分钟，节点A更新了这条数据，但因为他的时钟慢，他写进去的时间戳居然是十点零零分。
[S01] 哇，那系统一看十点零一分比十点零零分新，所以直接把A真正最新写进去的数据当成旧数据给扔了。
[S02] 完全正确，这就叫静默数据丢失。数据就这么悄无声息的没了，连个报错都没有。
[S01] 天呐，这太可怕了。那像谷歌这种大厂是怎么解决这种时间问题的？比如他们的spanner数据，
[S02] 谷歌的思路非常颠覆。既然绝对的时间不存在，那干脆就不提供绝对时间。他们搞了个叫True Time的API.
[S01] 听起来很霸气，真实时间。
[S02] 名字很霸气，但它给你的结果却非常模棱两可，它绝不会给你一个单一的时间戳。
[S01] 那它返回什么？
[S02] 它返回的是一个质性区间，它会告诉你，我现在的时间最早可能是十点零一分零五秒，最晚可能是十点零一分零七秒。这是一个带有误差范围的区间。
[S01] 把时间看作一个有误差的区间？
[S02] 对，只有当两个事件的质性区间完全不重叠时，系统才能百分之百确定谁先谁后。如果区间重叠了，对不起，系统必须强行等待，直到这个不确定性的时间框口过去。
[S01] 哇，时间不再是一个点，而是一团迷雾，必须要等迷雾散去才能行动，这真的是个绝妙的思维转换。好，就算我承认网络会随时丢包，时间也会天天撒谎，但我还有最后一道防线啊，我的CPU
[S02] 哦。
[S01] 现代SERVER的CPU一秒钟能执行几十一条指令吧。就算外面的世界再怎么乱，我程序正在执行的那段代码总是一望无前的吧，它总不可能凭空停住吧。
[S02] 嗯，很遗憾，你最后的这道防线也是不存在的。
[S01] 为什么？
[S02] 在资料里，这被称为进程暂停。你可以想象一下，一个节点可能会毫无招照的突然睡着了。
[S01] 睡着了，CPU好端端的怎么会睡着？
[S02] 最常见的一个罪魁祸首叫全局垃圾回收，也就是GC.
[S01] 哦，Java里常说的那个。
[S02] 对，很多现代编程语言在清理内存垃圾时候，为了安全会触发一种叫stop the world的操作。
[S01] 全局暂停。
[S02] 没错，在那个瞬间，它会把所有正在执行应用程序逻辑的线程全部冻结，又或者在云环境里，虚拟机正在进行时事迷迁，整个操作系统直接被挂起。
[S01] 冻结多久？应该就几毫秒吧。
[S02] 正常是几毫秒，但在极端情况下，一个线程可能会被冻结十几秒甚至几分钟。
[S01] 几分钟？
[S02] 对，最恐怖的是这个被冻结的线程，它自己根本意识不到时间已经流失了。等它醒过来的时候，它会接着执行下一行代码，仿佛什么事都没发生过一样。
[S01] 这听起来简直就像是科幻电影里的休眠舱啊，人在里面睡了一百年，醒来以为才过了一晚。
[S02] 没错，就是这种感觉。
[S01] 那让我们把刚才讲的这些可怕元素全部拼凑在一起，描绘一下资料里提到的那个终极灾难场景。假设在一个数据库群里有一个主节点，
[S02] 嗯。
[S01] 他刚刚获得了一个叫租约的东西，拿到了修改底层存储的唯一权利。但就在这个时候，他突然触发了长达一分钟的机息暂停，整个人被彻底冻结了。
[S02] 好，这个时候因为网络超时，其他的节点等了他三十秒没反应，就理所当然地认为哦，老大已经挂了。
[S01] 于是剩下的人赶紧举行投票，选出了一个新主节点来接管工作。新老大开始正常的接受用户的上入请求。但就在这个时候，高潮来了，那一分钟过去了，那个处于冻结状态的旧老大突然醒过来了。
[S02] 对，他现在变成了一个名副其实的僵尸。由于他没有任何时间流失的感知，他低头看了一眼自己手里的租约，心想，诶，时间还没到呢，我依然是老大。
[S01] 于是这个僵尸直接越过了新的主节点，野蛮地冲向底层的存储系统，试图去修改数据。
[S02] 如果他真的写进去了，两个老大同时往数据库里写数据，那整个系统的数据就被彻底搞烂了。这就是分布式系统里臭名昭著的脑裂现象。
[S01] 脑裂，听着就疼。早期的系统是不是经常在这个坑里栽跟头？
[S02] 太多了。早期的HBase之类的，就因为这个出过无法修复的数据损伤问题。
[S01] 那么，到底怎么才能防范这个拿着旧租约去搞破坏的僵尸呢？如果在分布式系统里，单个节点连自己是不是老大都能产生幻觉，我们还能相信谁？
[S02] 这里真正迷人的是真相，从来不是由单个节点决定的，真相是由多数派投票决定的。
[S01] 也就是仲裁。
[S02] 对，为了防范僵尸进城，系统引入了一个非常聪明的机制，叫做隔离令牌。
[S01] 隔离令牌？听起来像是在僵尸脑门上贴了一张符，它具体是个什么形态的东西？
[S02] 你可以把它想象成一个单调递增的呃类似皇帝的年号，或者就是一个不断变大的编号。
[S01] 编号怎么用呢？
[S02] 系统每次选举出新老大发造租约的时候，都会给他附带一个比上一次更大的编号。比如旧老大拿到的令牌编号是三十三，当他暂停变成僵尸后，大家选出了新老大，所服务就会发给新老大一个编号为三十四的令牌。
[S01] 可是等等，那个僵尸醒过来的时候，他手里拿着三十三号令牌，他依然认为自己是合法的。他拿着三十三号去命令底层的存储服务器，凭什么能给拦下来？
[S02] 秘密就在底层的存储服务器上。存储服务器可是有记忆的。当新老大拿着三十四号令牌去写过数据之后，存储服务器就会聪明的记住，我见过的最大编号已经是三十四了。
[S01] 我懂了。所以当带着编号三十三的僵尸气势汹汹地冲过来，试图写入数据时，存入服务器一看，不好意思，我已经听命于三十四号长官了，你这个前朝的三十三号命令无效。
[S02] 对，直接拒绝他的写入请求。那个僵尸就这么被完美的隔离在系统之外了。
[S01] 哇，直接把他给拒之门外了，这真的是工程师的极致智慧啊。既然我们没办法组织时间撒谎，也没办法组织进程，突然睡着，那我们就用一个绝对不可逆的单向数字序列，也就是隔离令牌，硬生生打破了时间谎言带来的威胁。
[S02] 没错，用逻辑的确定性去打败物理世界的不确定性。
[S01] 但我还有一个很现实的问题，这些防范机制，不管是多数派投票还是隔离令牌，逻辑上听起来那叫一个完美，但我们怎么知道它写上代码之后真的有效呢？你怎么能在生产环境里干等着一只海狸去把电缆咬断，或者干等着一只极其罕见的几十秒的垃圾回收化半停来测试BUG吧。等到那个时候，用户的前兆就没影了。
[S02] 这确实是整个行业痛了很久的问题。以前大家流行搞混沌工程，就是在生产环境里故意删机网线，关死物器，看看系统能不能扛得住。
[S01] 像Netflix的Cute Monkey那种。
[S02] 对，但这种方式其实还不够精确，因为物理故障的组合是无限的，你很难碰上最极端的死角。所以资料里提到了目前最前沿的一种终极测试方法，叫确定性模拟测试，简称DST.
[S01] 确定性模拟，听起来像是在造一个类似黑客帝国那样的虚拟矩阵。
[S02] 形容得非常贴切。像FoundationDB或者Tiger Beetle这种现代的底层数据库，他们在设计的第一天就把物理世界的那些不可控因素给剥离了。
[S01] 怎么剥离？
[S02] 在测试的时候，他们根本不使用真实的网卡发送网络包，也不看真实的系统时间，甚至连真实的系统调度都不用。他们把整个分布式系统变成了一个完全受控的状态机。在这个模拟器里，工程师就是上帝。
[S01] 上帝视角，也就是可以随意暂停快进时间。
[S02] 没错，在模拟器里，工程师可以极其精准地导演一场好戏。比如让节点A在发送数据包的一瞬间发生长达一分钟的织机暂停，同时命令交换器丢弃节点B的确认包，并且让节点C的时钟刚好发生三秒钟的偏移。
[S01] 我的天呐，这种极端的巧合在现实世界里可能要跑几年甚至几十年才会碰上一次吧。
[S02] 对，而且一旦发生就是毁灭性的BUG,事后看录制根本查不出来。但在模拟器里，通过几分钟的疯狂快进，工程师就能跑完现实中几年的运行状态。最神奇的是，只要发现BUG,不管多复杂，都能百分之百完美重现当时的每一行代码状态。
[S01] 太离谱了，这就是降维打击啊。正是这种变态的测试，极大地保证了我们今天使用的分布式系统底层的可靠性。
[S02] 没错，这是工程学上的奇迹。
[S01] 哇，今天这趟深潜真的是信息量巨大，但又让我们无比兴奋。那么这一切到底意味着什么呢？
[S02] 意味着什么？
[S01] 意味着下次当你在手机上点开一个APP,看到页面瞬间刷新，各种信息丝滑地呈现出来的时候，你应该知道这份丝滑和可靠，并不是因为底层的物理世界很完美。恰恰相反，它是建立在工程师们深深承认底层的绝对不可靠之上的。
[S02] 是的。
[S01] 我们接受了网络会断，接受了时间会撒谎，也接受了私服器随时可能变成僵尸，然后用诸如质性区间、反规划的令牌、多数派投票，这些充满智慧的机制，在物理世界的废墟之上，为你建起了一座无懈可击的逻辑高塔。
[S02] 这是一场软件逻辑与物理混乱之间永不停歇的伟大博弈。
[S01] 不过在节目的最后，我想给你留下一个发人深省的想法。
[S02] 哦，是什么？
[S01] 你看哦，在今天我们探讨的所有这些精妙的防范机制中，无论是应对网络超时，还是防范僵尸进城，我们其实都默认做了一个极其基础的前提假设。
[S02] 就是假设这些节点至少是诚实的对吧？
[S01] 没错，不管他们是宕机了，暂停了还是掉线了，他们只是出了故障，但他们绝不会故意向系统发送伪造的或者恶意的虚假数据。
[S02] 但是如果他们不仅会出故障，还会作恶呢？
[S01] 对，如果硬件因为航空航天环境中的强辐射发生了未反转，导致它疯狂地发送看似合法，但全是错误的指令呢？或者更现实一点，如果在一个庞大的金融交易网络中，有一台实服器被黑客给控制了，黑客故意去伪造我们刚才说的隔离令炮，甚至向不同的节点发送不同版本的谎言，试图彻底欺骗整个系统呢？
[S02] 哇，那就全乱套了。
[S01] 这在资料中被称为拜占庭故障，也就是大名鼎鼎的拜占庭将军问题。想想看，如果你要设计一个系统，其中连节点没有撒谎，这个底线都不能相信了，甚至连负责防守的将军里面都混进了叛徒，你该如何让这个充满恶意的系统依然能达成共识呢？
[S02] 这个坑可就太深了。
[S01] 这可是分布式系统皇冠上最璀璨而使最烧脑的一颗明珠。把这个烧脑的问题留给你去慢慢解决。下次当你再点击屏幕上那个丝滑的按钮时，别忘了在这个小小的动作背后，有一整支虚拟的军队正在竭尽全力对抗着整个物理世界的混乱。感谢你的收听，我们下个深度解析，再见。
[S02] 下次见。